good evening i'm lieutenant ray spencer
i'm the homicide lieutenant with the las
vegas metropolitan police department
i'm out here this evening to brief you
on a homicide investigation that we are
conducting
in the 5600 block of east sahara
which is an apartment complex in the
eastern part of the valley near the
intersection
of sloan and sahara the details that i
have right now are very preliminary
but at around 8 pm tonight officers
responded
to an unknown trouble call at the
apartment complex behind me
when they arrived they were met by a
neighbor who stated that there was a
female in an upstairs apartment who was
screaming for help
that somebody was inside their house and
that
neighbor went in to render aid at that
point the female was found
suffering from multiple injuries that we
believe she sustained
from blunt force trauma being someone's
fist or being choked we don't know
specifically
what led up to the struggle what we have
learned
is that the suspect lives in an
apartment directly below
the victim the suspect was involved in a
domestic disturbance with his
live-in girlfriend during the domestic
disturbance he became upset
left the apartment went upstairs and
appears to have gone into an
uh neighbor's house unprovoked and
physically killed her during a physical
assault again we're
still trying to figure out what uh how
she died we know there was a violent
confrontation inside the apartment
neighbors could be hurt a neighbor has
told us that
they heard the victim screaming why are
you here
why are you inside my apartment stuff to
that effect
at that point the male suspect fled the
apartment and we are actively looking
to locate him he is a hispanic male in
his early 30s
our victim is a black female in her
early 60s so again at this point we
believe the incident is
completely unprovoked and a result of
the suspect
at some point was again in a domestic
with his girlfriend which was
completely unrelated and went upstairs
and
killed the woman who was inside of her
apartment so with that i will take a
couple questions
but again still very early in the
investigation
i'm sorry miss can you uh give some more
information about the suspect who you're
looking for
he's a hispanic male he's uh 32 years of
age who lives in the apartment complex
we're still trying to get some further
information as far as his whereabouts
again that's very early on in the
investigation do you know if this
victim and the suspect had prior
interactions we don't know that
at this point again what we're what
we're learning from statements that were
overheard and from neighbors is that
it appears he just left his apartment
went upstairs
don't know how he got into the
neighbor's apartment
but then uh physically beat her up
and killed her during that assault is
the woman with we lived with downstairs
okay was she injured at all
um her and her children are not injured
we are speaking with her right now
we're conducting those interviews as as
i'm talking to you
yeah you mentioned trauma do we have any
idea what type of weapon was used
if any we don't that's the what we're
still trying to determine right now is
exactly
what injury she received i mean we know
she was battered
originally we thought there was a
potential that injuries were from a
gunshot but again we don't believe that
that's the case at this point we believe
it is
a physical altercation that led to our
death
at this point what's going to help you
guys solve this time and bring this and
bring this man
into custody well right now it's still
like i said early on the investigation
but we have probable cause right now for
this person's arrest we are actively
looking to locate him and take him into
have that savannah's custody again still
we're still in that process as far as
canvassing and
talking to witnesses i know you guys are
still investigating the relationship
between
this man or this woman would you say she
was innocent in all this did she do you
think she had any
uh interaction with this man or know him
again as far as them knowing each other
i don't know but i know she was not
involved in the domestic disturbance i
know she was inside of her apartment
and that the suspect left his apartment
went upstairs
went inside her apartment and that is
when she was killed so there's nothing
at this point
that indicates that um to answer your
question yes
she is a innocent victim that was inside
of her apartment
and then just a quick unrelated question
we're hearing about some incident at
boulder station
uh people evacuated from a floor do you
guys know anything about that i have no
idea regarding the boulder station i
well i do know there's an incident
happening at boulder station but i don't
know any specific details for it all
right thank you guys